Sara's with us in Savannah Georgia
hi Sara how are you good how are you do
better than I deserve what's up I'm
calling because I have a year and a half
left in school I've set out for the last
year due to financial reasons of course
I have 29 thousand in student loan debt
and I'm just trying to figure out is it
worth going back to schools if they got
more debt to complete the degree or just
work on tackling the debt and also I'm
currently engaged and we're trying to do
like a cruise wedding so I'm just trying
to figure out which is that Wow and so
what do you make I make twenty-eight
thousand six hundred a month I mean a
year I'm sorry yeah and be nice yeah and
what does he make 26,000 yearly okay
and what are you planning on spending on
your wedding
um well if we do the cruise destination
is looking at about 5,000 okay and do
you have five thousand right now no when
when is the wedding we were looking at
tours November of this year okay so can
you save five thousand between the two
of you by then yes we started budgeting
this year good and we figured by the
time April comes we should have at least
a five thousand okay good that's a good
plan all right so we're going to pay
cash for the wedding your whole wedding
expense is five grand
yes okay it's an inexpensive way to do
it that's good and kind of a cool thing
I like it when you are married your
household income will be about $55,000 a
year correct okay you make you have
$29,000 in death do you have any other
debt I just bought a car you just bought
a car yeah because I didn't have my
thousand dollars base for my emergency
fund and my 2010 Ford Fusion needed some
repair
like CV axles great minor things but
they still add up so am i expensive a
car did you buy twenty thousand it's a
2014 Ford Fusion you're kidding me
you spent twenty thousand dollars on a
car yeah and you're broke
yes sell the car okay that was stupid
okay tell me you know that was stupid
I felt the brunt of it acted like three
days later when the gentleman was like
well you have 30 days to bring it back
and I'm like I just feel like a sister
are you within the 30 days um I brought
the vehicle yeah I think my 30 days I
might have just ended last week yeah
call them and call them and beg them
uh-huh to let to let the 30 days count
and let you take it back and you go and
you go get you a thousand dollar car
okay you might you not have honey you'd
only don't even don't even start talking
okay not after doing that I'm giving you
hard time you have to know that was dumb
you make $28,000 a year you signed up
for a $20,000 car debt and you are
already $29,000 in debt on your student
loans and broke yeah that you have to
hear that okay I'm not trying to be mean
to you but you got to break this thing
out of your brain or you're going to
constantly as a couple be wandering back
into this mess and I'm not going to be
able to help you because you're going to
continually go back to this back to the
slaughter I mean you just walked out
right in front of a gun and said shoot
me I mean it just I don't want I don't
want you to live your life like that
honey
so here's what I'm going to do I want
the two of you as my wedding gift to go
through Financial Peace University
that's our nine week series once you get
that car taken back call them today and
once you get your little little beat or
car or some kind to get by until you get
some this mess cleaned up now what were
you studying in school
Healthcare Administration Healthcare
Administration
okay and what do you do for a living now
I'm an assistant manager at the DMV okay
so you're not in the healthcare field
yeah do you want to be in the healthcare
field I do okay
can you study that at night and finish
it in pay cash as you go maybe after the
wedding yes but some of the classes do
require me to be in the actual school do
they have do they offer them at night
yes but with my work schedule I don't
generally get off in time to take those
clothes yeah you might have to rearrange
your work schedule in order to finish
your degree but I don't know that you
necessarily have to do completely all
school or all work my point is maybe we
can finish up school while we're working
while we're married and while we're
paying off the debt and but pay cash for
the school as you go you pay cash for it
and whatever you're going to do don't
add debt pay cash for whatever you do is
you go work your way down through it
that way and and pay cash for cars as we
go pay cash for the wedding you already
got that one on the run good for you
that was a good decision and we'll pay
cash for the cruise wedding and but
let's let's say let's take as many
classes as we can and then if we have to
talk to the B & B and say guys I got to
dial back a little bit because I'm this
close to finishing and for one semester
here I need to be able to take off on
Tuesday nights you know okay they'll
work with you or if they won't find a
different job that's kind of where I'm
at yeah but I wouldn't just quit my job
to go back to school full-time no no no
okay
this more so for more income okay I'm
looking for yeah I think I think you can
make more with your degree and I think
it's a good degree to finish and
healthcare is a good field to be in
particularly Healthcare Administration
with as much up evil and chaos as there
is in that world someone that goes in
there with a cool head in the middle of
all this mess can probably you know do
some good for some companies and with a
little bit of academic it you know under
your belt so you're right on track but
the glaring thing in this disc
is this poor car and please talk them
into you and your fiance go over there
and go hey we just got engaged and you
guys please if we have to write you a
check take the count this in the thirty
days even if we give you a thousand
dollars just to say thank you give them
a tip you know to pay the salesman or
something right
but be able to take the thing back
because it's just insanity the numbers
on that just take my breath away how bad
they are and I want you to get because
with no car debt and the wedding is
saved up and paid for and we're paying
cash for college as we go along and then
we can begin to knock out the twenty
nine thousand as well see you're going
to be in a really good place in a very
short period of time
but when you drop a twenty thousand
dollar stupid car loan in the middle of
it it just blows the thing up it makes
it very hard to pull off so really
really really bad decision there on that
one but you can recover from it let's
get out of it and let's do something to
get out of that deal please work very
hard to get out of it and don't use them
saying no and smiling as a as an excuse
you've got to work your way away from
that it's just really really bad so and
hold on Kelly I'll pick up I'm going to
put you through Financial Peace
University is my wedding present to the
two of you what the two of you two go
through the class together and you'll
see what I'm talking about it'll start
to come together for you and you just
you see how avoiding debt causes you to
be in a position to be outrageously
generous and to build wealth hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
now
[Music]